a couple days ago on another podcast uh
he went off on Elon Musk and that was
really why we eventually decided to do
uh the segment we're doing right here we
now have the spectacle of Elon
completely misusing his opportunity to
to live a fulfilling life oh God we
already we already talked about Trump
now we know we got Elon we got the other
word elon's come out of your lips here's
another another friend who I have been
loath to talk about but right
um it's just like here's somebody who is
just the poster boy for having better
things to do and yet he's just tweeting
himself into a proper Fugue State I just
don't even know what to say about that
that is so disconnected from the reality
that I saw for two days for the hours
that I spent with Elon like the guy is
literally trying to put the train back
on the tracks relative of relative to
our ability to speak freely and
communicate with each other and
everything else he's taking a deeply
broken system that is Twitter broken
because of its collusion with the
government broken because of its
internal problems and the misdirection
of guys like Jack Dorsey who Sam was
thanking and he's trying to make it an
even playing field again yes he has a
whole bunch of other things to do he's
trying to get us to Mars for one that
that seems like a full-time job but he's
stepping into this and as I said in the
Twitter thread he didn't need this
problem he didn't need it and also 44
billion dollars that he bought it for
even if you're the world's richest guy
buy a sign for 44 billion that is
purging
probably hundreds of millions of dollars
a year is not necessarily the best
business situation he didn't do it for
fun I assure you although as I said he
was laughing a lot and kind of having
fun with people up there and sharing
memes with everybody and he showed us a
couple of funny videos and that sort of
thing he was genuinely as far as I could
tell unless I am unless he completely
had me Bamboozled unless Elon Musk
bought this thing just to punk everybody
and I don't think there's any evidence
of that he has brought all these people
back on Twitter he's clearly trying to
fix I mean it wasn't that I just talked
to him I talked to the programmers who
were getting the instructions from him
who are sitting there all day long
trying to fix this thing like what what
a what better fight is there than the
fight for free speech
foreign
[Music]